bonsoir romain de leiris président des
jeunes agriculteurs de l'aveyron merci
d'être avec nous en direct eu rc france
pour parler de ces manifestations qui
ont eu lieu aujourd'hui en france qu'est
ce que vous reprochez le plus à cette
loi alimentation beat loi et galim alors
je crois qu'elle a suscité beaucoup
d'espoir dans les mines de paysans ou
monde paysan à espérer juste retour de
la valeur dans les fermes avec un cycle
de construction du prix en marche avant
c'est-à-dire important des coûts de
regueb à des producteurs et en
additionnant les coups de deux
transformations et les marges des
différents intermédiaires ces principes
là aujourd'hui n'est absolument pas
respectée dans aucune filière sein des
filières agricoles ont travaillé à
construire leur coût de leur coût de
revient et qui sont pas ils ne sont pas
pris en compte au delà de la
construction et dans le prix de vente
ça veut dire me romain des dérives
pardon que cette loi elle n'est pas si
mal mais qu'en fait elle n'est pas
respectée et ça oui sur le principe je
pense qu'on touche eu beaucoup de notre
ca très positif qu'ont qu'on parte de
nos coups d'oreillers
mais elle n'est pas assez contraignantes
vis-à-vis des distributeurs ont tendance
puisque même si le principe est positif
le résultat n'est pas là donc il manque
des choses wallon n'est pas suffisamment
contraignant pour que nos valeurs alors
serge papin justement l'ancien patron du
système u 1 a été mandatée début octobre
pour trouver les moyens d'aller plus
loin que cette loi est galim l'une de
ses principales recommandations consiste
à rendre obligatoire la signature d'un
contrat pluriannuel entre l'agriculteur
et l'industriel qui va donc transformer
ces produits est ce que c'est la bonne
voie c'est la bonne solution selon vous
on peut prendre toutes les meilleures
initiatives du monde
ce ne sont pas respectées ça ne sert à
rien donc
appliquons déjà aujourd'hui
ce qui a déjà été fait en vain de
vouloir peut-être déjà les clous et une
fois que l'ensemble des critères qui
doivent être respectées le seront on
verra la nécessité d'aller dans les
plumes il faut il faut absolument durcir
l'uscri renforcer les contrôles sur le
dispositif qui existe qui existe nulle
ça veut dire qu'un gouvernement lieu
comme vous dites d'appliquer les choses
peut-être dépenses son temps et son
argent avec des énième rapport qui dans
le fond vont ne servir à rien parce que
l'ambition paraissait plutôt loi sur le
papier oui oui je suis sur le pot qui
ont négocié ces deux là ce qu'on s'a le
constable on le partage à l'initiative
on peut on peut on peut y adhérer
après tout ils constatent sur nous sur
l'a22 production c'est que si klose toni
aylwin est loin du compte
pour donner un exemple précis tout le
monde puisse les comprendre
la filière laitière en google et à
celtel culte qu'il faudrait que les
éleveurs sont payés aux 2 400 euros la
tonne de lait chinois dignement de leur
métier
aujourd'hui sur le lit que j'ai vendu
sur le mois de février
le prix de base s'est même pas 330 euros
donc on boit d'eilat où les cartes qui
reste à combler pour émuler dignement
justement le travail des éleveurs
romain déléris on a du mal à comprendre
cette quoi mauvaise volonté de la part
des industriels pour vous avez en face
comment vous l'expliquez que soit soit
aussi compliqué aussi peu équitable pour
vos agriculteurs
donc je pense qu'il ya plusieurs aspects
le premier qui le premier qui me vient
en tête c'est le fait que aujourd'hui en
gros 75 % de l'alimentation est acheté
en grande surface et que face aux
agriculteurs il ya quatre opérateurs
on va pas citer le nom de tout le monde
les tout le monde de l'e coli donc il
n'y a pas encore de force totalement
défavorable aux agriculteurs
le point en juin optiquement aussi très
sensible d'ailleurs la puissance
publique les politiques leur s'incline
devant de vent on va dire la défense du
pour des packs que revendique notamment
jean-michel d'angleterre au détriment
des producteurs de destruction de
filières dans de valeur dans les filles
à la destruction de filières entières
dans le pays
quelques centimes de plus au kilo de
viande ou sur le haut / litre de lait
est permettent de mener correctement les
éléphants drogba ne sais pas c'est pas
un gros c'est pas un gros effort n'a pas
de consommateurs c'est juste quelques
centimes qui permettait collectionnant
aux éleveurs de vivre de leur métier
super fait des romains et les risques
les consommateurs seraient tout à fait
prêt à faire cet effort maintenant est
ce que les industriels et supermarchés
le sont parce qu'apparemment la balle
est dans leur camp quel serait le moyen
pour les consommateurs de plus vous
aider de jeter français en premier lieu
je pense que c'est le premier c'est le
premier signe que les consommateurs
peuvent peuvent faire pour soutenir leur
écriture de la culture française
désignée plusieurs années positivement
la culture la plus durable au monde dont
québec que les adultes que les
consommateurs français se tournent déjà
en priorité dans les polices racing que
le restauration collective gérée par an
par les collectivités locales à penser
de même je connais cet engouement est
que le consommateur sont très français
sur le premier ambassadeur de somalie
culture merci en tout cas romain dveri
ce président des jeunes agriculteurs de
l'aveyron merci en tout cas d'avoir été
en direct avec nous sur rt france